cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com I want to jump to the next
story ladies and gentlemen and now for
the coup de gras
from
ncherald.co.nz Donald Trump suggests
feeding migrants to alligators to fix
overrun border security
uh spoiler no we didn't but I absolutely
love the headline I am curious how many
migrants it would take to be fed to
alligators before they would stop Trump
posted a meme
disavow he wrote problem solved and it
says new border security and it's a
bunch of alligators those are alligators
what's the difference like crocodiles
have like skinnier faces right I I don't
I don't I'm not an animal zoologist they
both look really hungry we'll work for
food Trump did not did not suggest
feeding migrants to alligators because
their headline implies Donald Trump said
what if we capture a migrant and then
throw them into an alligator Den what
Trump was saying is a meme based on an
old story this is from uh New York Times
2019 shoot my legs and build alligator
moat behind Trump's ideas for the Border
it was a widely reported story that
Donald Trump wanted to put a bunch of
alligators in the Rio Grande is this is
not real life these are hoaxes the media
is full of crap and once again they're
full of crap Trump posted a joke but
I just I absolutely love the headline
like the reality these people live in
I mean no wonder Howard Stern hates
Trump I mean if I legitimately thought
Trump was going to kidnap migrants and
throw them into alligator pits I'd be
really concerned as well well this goes
back to the the consuming the headlines
digesting these crazy headlines and then
people actually believe it this will
probably be brought up in one of the
debates as an actual question yeah
Donald Trump
you're gonna say that he threw them into
the alligator's mouth exactly so now we
have this one this look at this tweet
from Bill malugan it's a total
free-for-all in Eagle Pass right now
Mass illegal Crossing taking place for
over an hour and a half almost two years
to the day we saw 15 000 Haitians under
the bridge in Del Rio we now have
thousands of predominantly Venezuelans
Gathering under Eagle Pass Bridge
yeah I'm sorry dudes like
the Republicans don't have your back
Democrats don't have your back they're
selling you out they're gutting the
system and they're doing with a smile on
their face so if this is the situation
we have and to be completely honest I
would say Trump joking about it isn't
appropriate
inappropriate why well the joke's funny
but we need real action this is a
desperate situation there's an emergency
declaration in Eagle Pass
take a look from the Daily Mail
Eagle Pass Texas declares state of
emergency as shocking photos showed
being overwhelmed by migrants with 4 000
streaming across the border today 4 000
today you know why the mayor wants money
why he declared a state of emergency he
wants money from the federal government
to help these people and bring more in
yeah they're not stopping it they're not
they're not issuing a state of emergency
to be like help help it must stop
they're saying no say to emergency we
need more money give us more so we can
send them to to your home in New York
yeah and this is I mean that's what uh
Alejandra Mallorca is like you know
testifies to where they're like you know
you're doing nothing to stop this
Invasion he's like actually we made an
app that makes it very easy for people
to come in Legally and it's like that's
the opposite of what we want you to do
dude like that's literally the opposite
and I mean it's the same thing that's
happening in uh the Italian
um Island where there's now yeah where
there's now 18 000 migrants to to a uh
six thousand five six thousand yeah I
mean so I mean this is a coordinated
plan right this is a coordinated
well-funded these ngos and supernational
organizations like the UN are paying for
people to travel instructing them how to
get around the American law every single
one of these organizations should be
rooted out and arrested and charged with
uh you know conspiring to circumvent
American laws it's and none of the you
know none of these people are actual
Asylum Seekers none of them are refugees
migrants yeah so I mean there's some
Chinese that that are coming over the
southern border that are coming as as
actually refugees they're trying to
escape China but yeah but like but but
generally speaking generally speaking 90
plus percent are not refugees they are
economic migrants we especially with
lampedusa the U.N issued this report in
like 2017 or whatever these are economic
migrants seeking jobs in Europe that's
it and the media lies and calls them
refugees over and over and over again
because they're evil
and they don't look at what's happening
when look you take a group of people who
have one set of morals and another
people with a different set of morals
and they fight
we want to avoid that we want people to
live together and so you look what's
happening in Europe and you have these
these these stabbings these murders
these horrible crimes it's like well
you're not properly assisting the
integration of people into your country
you're opening your border and letting
them run straight through what happens
violent crime and then that breeds more
racism people people take issue and they
they assume race is the problem when the
reality is two different cultures that
don't mesh and how about the reality of
nature people who don't have stuff are
going to take it when they want it so in
lampeduso you've got these videos of
people setting up barricades what are
they supposed to do these people come to
the island and now they're like now we
need food now we need shelter now we
need stuff and if they they can't they
can't menu they can't fabricate it from
thin air they're gonna take it from
someone yeah and let's even zoom out
from the kind of the political debate
regarding this issue and let's just look
at the logistics logistically this isn't
impossible to handle for a country large
or small so just pull back out of this
and just recognize we cannot do this
because we're not set up we don't have
the infrastructure necessary strictly
even from that perspective the fact that
that New York has basically buckled
under the the busing of a just a portion
of the migrants that are coming to Texas
and the city that has the financial
services sector based in it they have
the city itself has city taxes then
there's state taxes as well and they
can't produce uh uh you know they can't
take care of migrants they can't they
can't take you know to welcome the
migrants that just the ones they're
getting it should indicate to the rest
of America that these are massive
problems that a handful of states are
dealing with you know people in New
Hampshire aren't making a stink about
the people that are coming into the
country because it doesn't affect them
right and New York they were very happy
to be as NIMBY as it gets you know they
were they were like you know you
horrible people you horrible racists
down there on the on the border Texas
you're full of races how dare you turn
these people how dare you not take care
of them and then they get a portion of
them and the infrastructure is buckling
they're falling apart and now they're
calling uh their their mayor Donald
Trump yeah yeah and it's really calling
him Trump yeah so someone was saying
that he had he had Donald Trump
but the the point is like the rest of
the country should be able to see this
and say okay I at least can understand
because obviously New York can't handle
it they're they're it's you know they're
they're buckling under the pressure so
if New York City can't handle it with
the infrastructure of the money and
everything they do you can't expect you
know Texas and New Mexico and Arizona to
handle the type of influx it's not
possible and that's that's the beauty of
what's busing them to New York did is
you can't avoid it right because these
problems that are so massive in a place
like Texas where you have thousands of
miles of unoccupied land you can put
them on a base somewhere you can put
them in a tent somewhere and the the uh
you know they don't actually affect the
daily lives although then you know a
place like El Paso they obviously do
Eagle Pass they obviously do and it is
it is purely a matter of choice right
like we're making we're choosing to have
this happen and I think the uh the
Haitian example is a great example how
there was 15 000 people it was a crisis
it went on and on and then there was
like the scandal with the whipping it
got embarrassing the next day they were
gone the next day it got taken care of
so it's not a matter if we can't handle
this we can't do this this is all being
done on purpose this is all a choice
that we're making and I honestly don't
see an end to this to the extent that
why wouldn't the people in charge want
to keep a constant cycle going where
you've got the first world producing
excess amounts of goods shipping it to
the third world keeping their birth
rates High a pathway to where those
people in the third world are moving
into the first world in the first world
the cultural and and spiritual impetus
is to strip them of all of their
cultural identity fold them into this uh
you know Global homogenized soulless
plastic Society where the people that
come in don't have kids either by choice
or because they've been poisoned with
the poison in the food and Waters so
they die out within a couple Generations
only to be replaced by another so you've
got this like laundry cycle continuously
going where nobody has any cultural
um uh
staying power basically so there's never
enough people with enough culture to
overthrow the ruling classes just to
constantly in a constant influx of new
people being brought in uh deracinated
uh destroyed uh politically and
spiritually only to be replaced by
another crop for people I think it's
simpler than that it's an eternal win
for the Democrats yeah right the
Democrats look good when they say oh we
should we should take care of people
that come here they're all refugees Etc
et cetera they they always have the nice
sounding yeah the emotional the
emotional mode pull um and that pays
dividends the people that come in
they're like well the Democrats are the
people that want to have the services
that provide provided me with help when
I got in or helped with my family helped
me get my family in it's an eternal win
for Democrats it's a loser for the
American people right the American
people are the ones that are paying for
this the American people have to have to
make sure that the people that come into
the U.S have places to live and and they
have to share resources and and you know
jobs and all sorts of things you know
low-skilled workers coming to the U.S
makes it harder to get jobs for for
Americans that are here that's that's
something that's clearly obvious it's a
bad thing for the American people but as
long as there are enclaves of wealthy
people that are looking for uh you know
migrant workers and stuff like that or
that are looking to vote with their
heart and stuff like that you're going
to have Democrats that are going to be
like hey we can't be mean to these
people we can't we can't be we can't
turn them away we have to take care of
them Etc so it's literally an eternal
win for Democrats as it destroys the
country I just don't understand why we
haven't started just sending everyone to
Canada
[Laughter]
Canadian government would not be able to
reject it the way the super woke they
just be like oh you know we welcome
diversity it's like New York's not far
away man it's a couple hours well it's
gonna say it's about the same flight
right from El Paso to New York versus El
Paso up into Canada just get some buses
all right bus route to Montreal is only
a couple hours beautiful and then uh
I don't know it'll be interesting uh
people don't realize this though there
actually is a border crisis for Canada
migrants are going to Canada via where
they're they're uh in Upstate New York
I'm pretty sure that's where it's at
they're okay they're illegally crossing
the border because it's easier to get
into Canada than it is to get in the
United States obviously Canada's got
there there was a video I saw where uh
some people just like drove across the
border and then tried sneaking in that
way and they got caught but it really is
that easy I mean what do you think like
all this empty Wilderness they're gonna
catch people walking just through the
woods
there's actually a a photo that went
viral read it a while ago where the
border from Canada to the US was it was
a small chain literally just a chain
between two posts that was like a foot
off the ground and a sign hanging from
it saying Canadian U.S border and it was
like someone lived there and they were
like yeah if I if I go my backyard I'll
be in the United States and you just
literally walk in it's like what do you
do
maybe maybe the solution is which is
essay Canada we got a bunch of people
how would you like to have a bunch of
people man they got the space yeah
there's a lot of oil up there in the in
the in the Northern Territories or
whatever wherever in Canada amazing
Seafood they're gonna find out that if
you go to Canada and ask for health care
that you might get killed so and people
will be like no I don't want to go
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time